oh hello antes come I'm so glad and
excited to be here
I'm Constanza I'm from Buenos Aires
Argentina and I am a front-end developer
at Mercado Libre it's an e-commerce
company from South America and I'm part
of chicas program and own a community of
women then I'm sorry that aims to make
the taxi industry in Argentina more like
bears by giving workshops hosting
meetups and creating a platform for
display the profiles of women are
non-binary devs for given more
visibility no I'm here to talk about
life robots and cat
three of the most popular things on the
Internet
right we're going to see in this
presentation a child's life a designing
a epic theatre and its main part
building process the building process
and potential use cases of homo
dimension so when I was a four-year-old
child my family made me clean up my
bedroom put the toys always in boxes and
do the dishes and sometimes sweep the
patio but then I was so angry because
all he wanted to do was to play with my
friends and on toys it's right
so I used to have this dream that was
about creating robots that could help me
with these chores I had but then I grew
up and I still have chores even more
with more than before and now I have to
cut also Naraku and sometimes they had
to be they had to wait for me to be fed
needless to say I really get home early
to mind if I give them the day serving
in the morning they they did it but my
doom and when I get home at 9:00 they're
hungry so I needed to think of a way to
to give them the de servian twice a day
right ok so no I know that's why I
decided to to be a pet feeder I know
that nowadays there are a lot of options
that fill our our needs but some are
expensive and I can't afford them ok
that's the reason why I build a pet
feeder so then I started googling a
similar project that could guide me in
the development I saw a lot of examples
most of them were built on Python and
the structure was just four on one cut
however what I needed was something that
could feed both cuts at the same time
because I don't have much space in my
home and because it's cheaper than
- machines right so I knew that I will
need a cereal dispenser as a container a
servo motor to move the container blades
and a microcontroller to run the program
but I didn't know which one because
there are a lot of it in the market so I
have to decide if I will use a Raspberry
Pi or or an Arduino or something else
for some reason I thought that Raspberry
Pi will be the best option due to how
easy work how easy to work with is its
operating system so someone left me a
Raspberry Pi which a car I had to
configure from scratch as well
and I decided to use JavaScript to
develop the filler because I'm learning
I'm learning to program with this
language so I mean research found a
platform called johnny-five
that allows you to work in robotic
systems with Jenny with JavaScript but
before using Gennifer I installed rappy
recipe IO which is supplying that that
allows you to use Johanna file in the
raspberry on the res parity is packages
and for run or all of this stuff I used
no no J's so the configuration of raspy
IO and Johnny v is pretty easy you just
have to install it and require the
module in your JS file as I never build
something like that and my knowledge on
the subject was noon
[Music]
III know that from movies and that there
are conventions to connect for
connecting the world so all I wanted to
do was not to burn my house because it
would be terrible
so I after the the set up a of the
Raspberry Pi the first thing I try was
to turn it on tiny lights and to my
surprise it worked so thank you so I
joined the war of several motors and I
try to make one word but that part
wasn't that easy as I was suspecting so
the Raspberry Pi has a lot of pins were
to put the wires but you can't use any I
connected wires to different pins on the
servomotor didn't didn't work until I
found out that there are some things
that need to be connected to a specific
pin for example controlling the the
servo motor plate so to do that you need
to connect to a PWM there is a pulse
width modulation pin and the Raspberry
Pi has just four of them so I know I
connected to a wire there is GPIO 18 and
the others wires must be connected to a
5 volt or pin on a ground pin so during
the process
I learned that not all all servo motors
are the same some of them
turn 45 degrees others are hundred and
eighty degrees and their song with
continuous rotation I used all of them
until I found the one I need I didn't
know that you must consider the weight
of what you want to move so I had to try
several model for different way my house
was full of servos yes but I chose the
one that can receive three three point
two kilos so I'm sorry
yes that was a problem because I can't
stop I can make and stop the servo
motors and so the food overflowed a lot
of times are all over the table that
dropped my cuts crazy from fact that
they heard the sound of their food
getting out of the feeder and came
running to me and I start mooing and the
part was very funny and yeah for them I
get but it turns out that to move a
servo motors with continuous rotation
you need to move the blade clockwise so
it is necessary to set the top speed of
the servo of the several de Glace when
you want to stop so I set the feeder to
give them the food twice a day for that
I used an NPN package you just have to
set the minutes there 15 minutes and
then the day hours and that's it they
eat at 8:15
9:15 p.m. so thanks to Dodd
I left the the leopard filler running
and thanks to that I realized that the
filler wasn't working properly because
it was letting out the food every hour
so they were crazy yes they won they
want to do to eat all the food they they
can see so I'm sorry so for I spent a
lot of time trying to figure out what
was the problem and I found out that
name the library the package wasn't
working properly so I replaced that
package for another one and everything
goes right so the feeder was almost done
but one day I make cuts cut up really
really early like fire and they started
mooing loudly I was so sleepy and I'm
trying to get up on filtered balls by
new but I knew that if I didn't get up
they will keep trying so that was a
point where I thought that I should
include a new feature
send an email from the comfort of my bed
and then go back to sleep so I started
researching and looking for other
packages and about time I felt like this
little card sticking its nose in every
package it's wrong until I write till I
got the right one for this project
so to then develop this new future
I found this package that allows you to
set up the email configuration it was
very very easy to include this package
in my project and in this in this case I
wanted the feeder to start working only
if I was the email sender so this was
the feeder you can be before beginning
in a robot and after a lot of time
developing and testing Sasha ah yes the
feeder calls of Sasha I finish it with
this final structure that's awesome
with a little help of my my friend
because there are a lot of things that I
can do so we include those tools before
that was just one one one two and I want
to say that the decent separation of
those students is made by hand as I was
was made by hand so I can say that the
dream that I had when I was a child came
true
[Music]
[Applause]
and so building session and get it all
these achievements made me realize that
I wanted to do more projects involving
robotics and that there are a lot of
potential use cases of home automation
that I would love to implement like
controlling non smart things like lights
or the air conditioner or controlling
the temperature of a room so I think
that it's you can build this feeder just
with a little JavaScript knowledge it's
not too complicated it's a nice activity
to teach how to code even if there are
parts that involve not coding like
building the structure including pieces
pieces etc why is a nice activity agent
to teach to code because you can teach
variables conditionals using packages
setting up microcontroller so you are
introducing the beginners to the art of
set it on their computers so I don't
know much JavaScript because I started
learning to program like two years ago
but I'm sure that there are amazing
projects to be built and to be shown
maybe those projects can inspire others
are other people to do the things and to
facilitate chores or change how they
interact with their home just with a
little bit of code so that's I am I have
[Applause]
[Music]